[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
the distance between Heaven and Earth is
no greater than a thought
[Music]
even foul water will put out a fire
[Music]
the winner has many friends the loser
has good friends
[Music]
a fish sees the bait not the hook a man
sees the prophet not the danger
greed keeps men forever poor even the
abundance of this world will not make
them rich
[Music]
remember you have no companions but your
shadow
[Music]
it's difficult to take a wolf cub
without bringing in the whole pack
[Music]
an idiot can ask more questions than 10
wise men can answer
rich is he who has no debts fortunate is
he who has no handicap
conquer one with your hands a thousand
with your head
two bears in one cave will not end up
well
foreign
Ty is the source of success
while horses strong travel to see places
he who cleans up the dirt washes away
happiness
[Music]
he who wants to build high must dig deep
if the mind is clean the Fate is good
thank you
it is easier to catch an escaped horse
than to take back an escaped word
do not start if afraid once begun do not
be afraid
a tiger wearing a bell will starve
don't look for bad things in the good
that you do
[Music]
he who drinks dies he who does not drink
dies as well
[Music]
don't undo your boot laces until you
have seen the river
a donkey that carries me is worth more
than a horse that kicks me
[Music]
in anger is an action doomed to failure
each country's Customs are different
just as each Meadow's grass is different
foreign
[Music]
likes to eat fresh fish but will not go
near the water
[Music]
it favors those who endeavor
to the crow his child appears White
to the Hedgehog His Child appears soft
once you have locked your door you are
the Emperor of your own domain
the living are denied a table the dead
get a whole coffin
a bad person's voice is loud
do not scorn a weak Cub he may become a
strong tiger
[Music]
the rope breaks where it is thinned
the Supreme treasure is knowledge the
middle treasure is children the lowest
treasure is material wealth
the more you listen the more you give
yourself room for doubt
foreign
[Music]
exceeds the Folly of stupidity
a man falls seven times and Rises eight
[Music]
the last camel gets the heavy load
better to suffer in Liberty than to
Delight in captivity
[Music]
don't just sit sit and polish
you can't put two saddles on the same
horse
[Music]
the child learns to walk by Falling Down
there are men who walk through the woods
and see no trees
[Music]
the meat biting tooth is in the mouth
the man biting tooth is in the soul
the sun illuminates the World Knowledge
illuminates the man
wolves come during rain
wise men talk about ideas
intellectuals talk about facts common
men talk about food
[Music]
don't look a gift horse in the mouth
[Music]
a person's smile is hotter than the sun
will come with or without the rooster
the stone thrown up will fall back on
the thrower
Stag's horn is tender when you're hungry
a lamb's lard is tough when you're full
goats meet while it's hot
avoid popularity it has many snares and
no real benefit
even a mold feels strong when it is in
its hole
[Music]
a dog Hoards bones it can't chew
[Music]
a calf thinks it can produce Bull's dung
a good man at 15 does not refer to youth
at a hundred he does not complain of old
age
an onion can be as sweet as honey if it
grows in your motherland
better to be the head of a wasp than the
tail of a lion
it is better to see one time than to
hear a hundred times
[Music]
men and women sleep on the same pillow
but they have different dreams
[Music]
prepare the pot before preparing the
milk
[Music]
a well-tailored boot does not wear out
even when a friend does something you do
not like he continues to be your friend
a thief hates the Moonlight an evil man
hates a just man
the one who conceals poverty will not
get rich the one who conceals loneliness
will not get a family
[Music]
a leader can never be happy until his
people are happy
[Music]
Fame like the wind spreads quickly
[Music]
small though a sparrow bee it protects
its nest
wealth until the first snowstorm hero
until the first bullet
drop by drop a river is formed
[Music]
until you get a Horse Ride a donkey
[Music]
the people's wrath can destroy even
fortresses
there is no good in anything until it is
finished
do not keep sheep you will not see
wealth
women who cheat can be recognized by two
things
but nobody knows what they are
oh
the fox starves staring at the Bull's
testicles
[Music]
[Music]